big storm on the East Coast the entire
northeast is being hit by winter storm
Stella the first blizzard of 2017 that's
the story yeah of course now that
Obamacare is gettin repealed it's nice
to see something still covering half the
country fladam routing is not happy did
you know this Vladimir Putin is
reportedly frustrated by the lack of
progress in u.s. Russian diplomacy since
President Trump took office yeah he's
not happy yeah in fact Putin so
frustrated today he called Trump and
threatened to fire him seriously ugly
ugly D press secretary Sean Spicer now
says that President Trump didn't
literally mean that President Obama
wiretapped him he also said Donald Trump
didn't literally mean for people to vote
for him
I can't do it my hair is not going down
today today president Trump had lunch
with a Saudi prince yeah
Trump told the Saudi prince we have a
lot in common my wife doesn't leave the
house either this sermon the show is
free let me remind you you pay nothing
okay White House strategist Steve Bannon
is under criminal investigation for
voter fraud yeah yeah reportedly he
voted last year in Florida while still
technically a resident of 1930s Germany
okay enough politics check this out an
Ohio couple has been arrested
for faking their own murder yes I know
hi Oh couple is arrested for faking
their own murder people grew suspicious
when the couple changed their facebook
status - we've been murdered sad
new research just came out it finds that
consuming potatoes and alcohol can lower
your sperm count
so fellas this st. Patrick's Day could
be our last I'm sorry if that were true
I wouldn't be alive
that's [ __ ] there's no way I'm one
of six kids there's no way that's all we
had how'd your taser that's what my
parents greeted me every morning have
you had a tater and they threw it at me
pick me off the head and they're not
even front they weren't born in Ireland
now they just talk like pirates
you'll get your favor hope you enjoyed
that folks my parents are watching at
home look but none of this happened last
night big night for TV last night was
the season finale of ABC's The Bachelor
and tonight is the season premiere of
The Bachelor spin-off herpes in paradise
it sounds like you're really looking
forward to that one oh I love herpes in
paradise oh yeah taser
you